labrecque a plus de place c'est pas
évident que ma qu'on puisse aller au
jusque là mais je crois que au delà au
delà de toutes ces péripéties et de tous
ces discours on va vers une
recomposition politique il faut voir
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord là
dessus c'est à dire que macron occupe un
très vaste espace et un effet jeu tout à
fait d'accord avec carole barjon il
élargit chaque jour c'est à dire et et
curieusement il élargit surtout à droite
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment ça va
être un cas historiques macron sauté aux
yeux l'homme qui aura escalader
l'everest par la face gauche et qui aura
peut-être régner sur l'everest par la
droite
ça risque d'être ce paradoxe là et avec
quelques dindon de la farce au passage
alors est d'offrir et les autres qui
monte et oui qui les repoussent à
l'école ça et franchement en matière de
choquer moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
après je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec le diagnostic de deux bouquets sur
macro mais on va quand même pas se
déclarer choqué dans le combat politique
quand macron lui-même rappelez-vous a
très lourdement rappelé oradour sur
glane pendant la campagne électorale
contre le front national
alors qu'on peut pas dire que marine le
pen soit vraiment vraiment tout seul